good morning uh welcome to
the second day of the simon's 10th
anniversary workshop uh our first talk
today is
by iridium
needs no introduction we know her
through a lot of work on
the proof of the new proof of bcp
theorem
high dimensional expanders and lots of
other things uh today's uh it will tell
us about some breakthroughs in locally
testable codes
okay hi
thanks for the introduction uh
you can hear me and you can see me
[Music]
yes yes okay all right thank you
okay hi everybody um thanks so much for
the invitation to participate in this
uh wonderful celebration of the simon's
institute 10th anniversary i'm really
sorry
to not be there with you in person and
i'm saying that not because
it's a nice thing to say really i feel
like i'm missing out
uh unfortunately there was also a as you
may probably have heard there was a big
conference here celebrating money now
60th birthday uh which ended
well it's actually going on still right
now
so i
had to
choose
but anyway really
in my heart i'm also at berkeley and the
simon's institute has played such a big
a
role in this research community it's a
bit hard to believe that it's only been
10 years
since its inception it's had a huge
impact i think on the entire community
but i can say for me personally and the
students that i know
and so i honored to be part of this
celebration
okay so i'm going to talk about
expanders expansion
starting with graphs and then moving to
codes and pcps and proofs
so let's begin
yeah
all right so expanders
expanders are
such a fundamental thing these days in
theoretical computer science also in
other areas in mathematics group theory
geometry
and so on that i really don't need to
explain or define what they are but let
me do it anyway
so expanders are graphs that
contain some interesting
uh contradiction in that every vertex in
the graph you can think of it as a
network so every vertex is like a person
on a network and it's only connected to
a very small like a constant number of
other vertices so the degree is very
small the graph is sparse and the
contradiction is that even though it's
very sparse it's highly highly connected
and this is an expander graph
highly connected means that there's no
way you can kind of take a bunch of
vertices and cut them away from the
graph without having to cut many many
many edges okay so it's robustly it's
not only a connected graph it's robustly
connected and this is kind of the most
straightforward way
in which we think about expander graphs
and there have been
so many applications of expanders in
computer science and
by now i don't need to enumerate them
let me just give one example that will
be important for this talk
and this is the application to error
correcting codes
so what are error correcting codes
in a digital age we have data being
stored digitally transmitted digitally
and noise and errors happen all the time
so bits get flipped for various reasons
and a lot of the data
it's okay if some bits get flipped in a
photograph nothing
will get ruined
but in some data like in finance or
if it's a computer program and some bit
gets flipped
everything will be
a ruined and you you won't be able to
understand what's going on or worse you
might do something completely wrong so
we must protect our beats and be able to
recover from any
error that happens and this is why
we don't just
transmit the bits as they are we
actually encode them and
the hope is that we don't need to use
too much overhead and yet be able to
recover from any errors
you know every person encodes
his transmissions when you speak to
someone
and there's loud noise you might say the
same thing twice or three times until
you're sure the other person heard
but that's a bit wasteful if you
say something three times um you're only
using a third of your
channel and their correcting codes allow
you to do it much more efficiently
so what is an error correcting code it's
like a dictionary it's a bunch of the
strings
and and you have a mapping from a
message to a code word and instead of
transmitting the message you transmit a
code word and the the
nice thing about the code words is that
the guarantee is that every pair of code
words are is far apart so many bits are
different
and so if you transmitted the code
within a few bits got flipped
the receiver
will just search
you got some
corrupt code word he will search in the
space of
around the corrupt code word until he
finds the the nearest actual code word
and he knows that this is what you
transmitted assuming not too many errors
have happened
okay so of course the way i describe it
the search space can be exponential
that's not a very good thing but a good
code comes also with a good decoding
algorithm so you don't really need to
search in an exponential
search space and this is a decoding
problem you're given a received word you
know some errors may have happened how
are you going to clean it and remove all
the errors and find the nearest code
so a
beautiful a
construction in 96 by simpson's film and
show how to use the expanders to a
construct
error correcting codes that can be
decoded in linear time
in a
paper i think in the same year spillman
also showed how to do how to
construct another code that can actually
be also encoded in linear time
and for this
they used expander graphs now
the question of error correcting codes
suggests some kind of geometric thing
because you're trying to put points
in this hamming space and you want to
put them far apart from each other
nothing in this problem suggests using
an expander graph which we said is like
a robust network
but somehow
this is useful and the way it's useful
is that their idea was to use the
expander
to describe the linear constraints of
the code so for example you would put a
constraint
you would put bits on the edges and you
put constraint around every
vertex
and the
reason and because the constraints are
on an expander means that you cannot
just put a bunch of the
ones in a small location and everywhere
else zero without many constraints being
unhappy kind of many constraints will
see both the ones and the zeros and not
not be satisfied so somehow the
expansion is is pushing the set of ones
to expand and expand
and that gives you distance between
different code words
furthermore the expansion allows you
to have a big flipping algorithm that
basically looks at a bit and if the
constraints around it are unhappy just
flips it and somehow this simple
algorithm will converge to the
non-corrupt codeword if your graph is
sufficiently expanding so somehow
expansion
plays an important role in this
both in the construction improving
distance and also in the algorithm
okay another application
of expanders
of course there are many many
applications i just chose the ones that
fit my story
a another application is for pcps so
before i describe the application let me
tell you a little bit about
pcps these are probabilistically
checkable proofs so this is really a
celebrated
theory within a theoretical computer
science
the
famous pcp theorem it was proven
more than 30 years ago
and what it says is that every np
statement a statement that you can prove
with an np witness
you can actually prove in a much more a
robust fashion in a way that it can be
checked verified
not by reading the entire proof and
checking it but rather by doing some
random
tests
in this random test we'll only read a
constant number of bits in the new
robustified pcp proof
so the statement is almost it's hard to
believe it's almost unbelievable
because proof is such a volatile object
you know a bug somewhere can really ruin
the entire proof so how can you make it
into a robust object
and nevertheless sorry nevertheless and
by now it's been 30 years we got used to
it so we know that pcbs exists and
we understand the
formalism that allows this to happen i'm
not going to go into all the details
just to say that we really have a very
well developed
theory around this and many many
applications both to optimization to
prove hardness of approximation and even
to much more
new and modern real-world applications
to a cryptocurrency and cloud computing
where
you have this asymmetry between the
cloud that has a lot of computing power
and your mobile phone say that has a
small computing power and you want to
check that you know
your cryptocurrency is being
a constructed correctly
and
you want to do this without spending too
much computation power so you use these
kinds of pcps not exactly
only that you need some crypto and so on
and it turns out that like in the case
of error correcting code expander graphs
are useful are useful components in some
constructions of probabilistically
checkable proofs
and let me uh
tell you a little bit about that in
one more slide
but uh
[Music]
how can i pick
okay
so i think i'm missing a slide i was
supposed to let me pick forward yeah
okay
i meant to go to this slide
okay so i want to show you how expanders
are useful in constructing a
probabilistically check world proof
so you need to kind of believe me that
to prove the pcp theorem it's enough to
prove a certain statement about three
coloring and the statement is
that
um
i have a graph i don't know if it's
three colorable or not
and there is a
i can define something called a gap so
the gap is
between uh
in one case
the graph is completely three-colorable
and in the other case
there is some no matter how you color
the vertices there's some fraction of
edges that are going to be poor you know
they're going to be monochromatic
they are not happy with this coloring
and the pcb theorem
is a
equivalent
to being able to take this graph and
encoding it into a new graph so that
if before you just knew that
in the yes case the graph is colorable
and in the low case it's not colorable
after the transformation there should be
a gap and in the no case the graph
should be not only not colorable but
actually any coloring must violate at
least one percent of the edges
if you had that then a test of the
colorability of the graph is just to
select a random edge read the two end
points and with
probability one percent you'll catch a
lie so if you repeat this 200 times you
will have very high probability of
catching approver if he's trying to
convince you of a false statement you
only need to read 200 colors and not the
entire
a proof
and the way uh
in this proof we do it
is by slow steps of gap amplification
every time we take uh the the graph that
we have
and we
kind of push the colors through an
expander and create a new vertex for
every little ball
in the old graph
and we use the expansion of this graph
to argue that somehow the colorability
of the new graph became worse than it
was before
if it was not colorable so if there was
already
any coloring needed to lie and to have
some errors then after this expansion a
the number of errors must be spread out
even more so some of the expansion is
allowing us to spread
the errors and this is kind of the gist
of the of the proof of this say gap
amplification
so this was a
paper from i don't know more than 15
years ago and it was very nice and
showed that pcps
can be constructed based on expanded
graphs
okay so now i want to kind of step back
and
talk about expanders say a little bit
more
so first question we can ask is do
expanders even exist i guess at this
point it's a bit
redundant to ask this question
expanders are everywhere it is known
that a random graph is a good expander
and we also have very good constructions
a number theoretic and group theoretic
constructions that give
best possible expanders if you measure
it in terms of
eigenvalue gaps we also have a really
really beautiful a
construction
by rangel vadan and victorson that
construct graphs by very elementary
methods a kind of recursive construction
called the zigzag construction
but let me talk a little bit more about
lps construction because it will help me
to get to
the high dimensional expanders
so lebowski philips in sarnak in 1988
constructed the ramanujan expanders and
the way they did it is they started from
the infinite tree so here in the picture
we see an infinite three regular tree so
here is
a vertex it has three neighbors and then
each neighbor also has three neighbors
and so on and so on it goes all the way
to infinity
and you can associate vertices of this
infinite tree with a certain group and
then use a subgroup to kind of glue
together different vertices if they're
in
the orbit of this sub-group
and this gives you a finite object and
what lps proved is that this finite
object is a very very good expander
and you know this has had tremendous
success many applications
and so
uh
following this a tremendous success
lubotsky somewhere else envisioning
almost 20 years later
thought maybe we should try to
continue this line of work in higher
dimensions so just like there is an
infinite tree there are also
higher dimensional analogs this one is
called the protips building
this is just like a graph where you have
vertices and edges
but instead of only stopping there you
also have higher dimensional faces in
this picture we also have triangles so
that's like a two-dimensional face
because it's like a little plane
okay and so what uh lsv did is that they
took this brutis building and
the way we should think of this is that
you have a triangle on every edge of the
triangle you glue more more triangles
and then each triangle on each one of
its three edges you glue even more
triangles and so on and so on so it's
like an infinite tree but it's like a
tree of triangles
okay so
what they did is just like in the
infinite tree you can use groups to say
that act on this building and you use
that to make a quotient that is a
infinite sequence of finite
quotients
and
these are portions of the proteins
building
you get finite construction it's really
beautiful it uses deep mathematics
it is somewhat inaccessible but slowly
surely we managed to understand
more aspects of it even without needing
to understand the entire deep
theory
and for example
now we can look not only at random walks
moving from vertex to vertex but also at
random walks that moves say from edge to
a triangle to an edge to a triangle so
there are many more random walks that we
can look at
i'm not going to define what the high
dimensional expander is because
there are several definitions and it's a
new theory and it's not quite stabilized
yet
so i think that instead it's better to
just understand what is a high
dimensional graph it's just a graph that
also has triangles
and
the property that really captures kind
of an interesting phenomenon here is
this local to global
looking at little pieces of the complex
through this notion of a link
so here is a
one a high dimensional graph that i drew
simplicial complex and you see it has
vertices edges and triangles and i want
to define what is a link so a link of a
vertex i just fix one vertex you see it
here and now its link is like its
neighborhood the vertices of the link
are all the vertex neighbors of this guy
and the edges in the link come from the
triangle so if this vertex and this
vertex share a triangle with our center
then we put an edge in the link so in
this picture the link of the pink vertex
in the middle is this five cycle
over here and it turns out that in high
dimensional expanders
uh
just by understanding
uh things about the links you can gain a
lot of understanding about the global
structure
of the entire object okay one really
really beautiful theorem is the
trickle-down theorem of this openheim
which is a kind of
in some ways dates all the way back to
garland from 1973 and this theorem says
that if you have a high-dimensional
graph
and every link is an expander and you
need it in some quantitative way
then the entire graph is an expander and
more accurately the entire connected
component
is an expander because of course we can
take separate copies and
the links won't know it
okay so uh high dimension so let me stay
here for a minute so
uh this is a the kind of historically
it's like the beginning of how we
understand
a high dimensional expander is the whole
structure is very hard to grasp
but this idea that the links give you
something about the whole object so
let's just look at
the links and
for
for me and other people
like me
if you're used to thinking about pcps
and property testing where you try to
understand a global object by looking at
local parts of it high dimensional
expanders seem like a wonderful gift
because they're very different from
things we know and yet they have this
property and you feel like wow this must
be useful for something
okay so one of the
first kind of big successes of this
theory was an application to fast mixing
of a random walks a
this actually has to do also with the
simon's program but i i i'll skip this
slide because i don't have enough
time but this is a really beautiful
result where they use the dimensional
expansion to analyze some very
important random walks on metroid bases
i want to get back to air correcting
codes
to connect to the stuff i talked about
before
so as we already saw error correcting
codes are often based on expansion and
expander graphs
and
when we started to learn about these
high dimensional expanders it was very
natural to wonder if we can use them to
create their correcting codes with new
properties
and there was a simon's a
program in 2017
a
on pseudorandomness and i happened to be
there in part of the program i spent
some time with tali kaufman
and others and here is a talk that i
gave you can almost ignore the abstract
just the title says high-dimensional
expanders and pcps now it's not that i
knew how to construct pcps with high
dimensional expanders it's more that i
was talking about the analogy between
these two objects and how they feel
similar and you know we should be able
to
combine these two things so this was
like
kind of a dream
that hasn't yet materialized maybe in
the future
but when while we were around the simons
at that time we talked we happened to
meet them dutchman who was on sabbatical
at berkeley back then
and we uh talked
about uh error correcting code which
seems like a natural next step and this
ended up being being a paper with the
italian unknown and also with prahlad
harsha and my student in balidi navon
we showed that certain constructions of
air correcting codes that were already
known
if you do them not on expanders but on
high dimensional expanders then you gain
some more
properties you can use the local pieces
of this code to do local decoding and
then you get global list decoding the
algorithm so that was a kind of a
confidence building because we
managed to prove something non-trivial
using these objects and it gave us
a somewhat
confidence to the future but let me also
mention that this work
it was uh it was very nice but really
later it was improved
uh
and generalized to give
algorithms for decoding much much better
codes
actually the almost optimal parameter
codes of tashma
and also for solving csps and high
dimensional expanders so there was a lot
of interesting
follow-up work here
and but one consequence also was that it
built our confidence and we decided to
apply to
the science institute for a summer
cluster so it's like a short program
much more flexible you don't have to
apply
too much in advance so this was really
perfect
and we applied for a summer cluster on
high dimensional expanders and codes
trying to bring together people and this
was really important because this
community
is still in the making right it involves
both mathematicians topologies
combinatorialist group theorists
many different kinds of people and of
course computer scientists and we came
to berkeley in the summer of 2019 and we
really had a great time
i think i came out of there with more
open questions than answers but
i learned a lot there was a lot of
insight and a lot of understanding like
where we should look and what we should
do
and there were several papers that came
out of that summer cluster
and
okay so my last topic that i want to
talk
is about the c cube problem
this was really on our minds when we
wrote the proposal for the summer
cluster
and it's the following question so if
you have an error correcting code and
you have a received word
a
it might be
i mean it's a good question to ask can i
tell how much noise happened to this
word i mean maybe it's not a code word
and maybe some bits got flipped can i
quickly check how much noise has
occurred okay this can be very useful
because cleaning a word from noise might
take a some computational effort and so
if i make a fast check and i see that
there's a lot of errors i can just ask
say for a retransmission
so this is exactly the kind of property
that locally testable codes give you
they allow you to do very very fast
constant number of bits
you need to read to check if uh
if a code word has undergone severe
noise
and the idea of locally adjustable codes
is not something that uh say
uh shannon or hamming would have even
thought about because the kind of codes
they were looking at like random codes
they're just never going to be locally
testable so the source of this kind of
object comes from the literature of pcps
and it really hinges on the relationship
between global properties like being in
the code and small local views
so it was very natural for us
to hope
that
high dimensional expanders will
enable us to construct ltcs
and indeed we managed to finally
do it it took maybe a bit longer than we
thought but uh
managed to construct these ltc's and
this is the c cubed refers to having
both constant rate and constant relative
distance and also being testable with a
constant number of weights so this is
called constant
illegality
we're even honored to
be invited to give a talk at the
breakthroughs lecture series at simon's
and we got to a
a to get a beautiful graphic that barry
vodka the graphic designer of the
simon's institute
did for us we constructed an object that
is like a high dimensional expander
except the two-dimensional faces are
squares and not triangles
for some reason and if you compare it to
the graphic that he made for us in the
summer cluster in 2019
to me they seem very similar here in the
in on the right
you see that
there's a like
underneath the water
what what happened
underneath the water there is this high
dimensional expander and on it you put
the bits of the code and then on top
there are these checks
and
on the left you see that instead of
triangles in the high dimensional
expander you have squares but the bits
are still
put on the square so
it turned out to be quite similar and
i mean it's kind of
in my career it's quite unusual that you
actually conjecture that you will be
able to do something and then it
actually happens so i feel very
lucky to have had that
and thanks to the simon institute for
participating in so many steps along the
way of this
road
okay let me finish with talking about
what's next
okay so i feel that high dimensional
expanders of course they're so much less
developed than expander graphs but they
have begun to deliver on their promise
they seem to be very interesting objects
with some really interesting properties
and i hope that they will find more and
more applications in the future
of course
to me it's very natural to hope
to harness them to construct pcps in the
past the
locally testable codes actually came
from pcps
and it's natural to
hope that if we manage to construct ltc
we might
be able to even use high dimensional
expanders to get you know new
constructions of pcp maybe cleaner maybe
better parameters who knows
and indeed we already have some future
program next summer that might touch
upon some of these
topics
at least so i hope
hey
okay so to end i just want to say really
thank you to the simon's institute thank
you to
shafi and to the staff thank you also to
jim simons for supporting this institute
i feel that it's really
a been a tremendous success
and i hope to see you in the 20th day
anniversary
questions ready
hi rit thank you very much for your
exciting talk really enjoyed it
um maybe it's a stupid question because
it's not really my field but i'll ask it
anyway i saw that in one of your slides
you gave a talk about this topic and the
title there was the soda randomness
and yesterday we heard a talk about
obfuscation and we've seen that the
missing part is the low degree of
pseudorandom
generator so my question is if you think
there's any way in which
locally testable codes or high
dimensional expanders can be used to
construct a low degree a centromere
low degree prgs
okay thanks to the question i actually
don't recognize the voice who who's they
asking
don't be done i'm opposed to carrot
berkeley i did my phd at ben gurion
okay cool okay nice to meet you so yeah
uh
i mean that's a wonderful direction to
uh to try and study i
i believe in some sense high dimensional
expanders are
even better they're not pseudorandom
because the term pseudorandom suggests
that you are trying to imitate
properties that random object has
whereas
high dimensional expanders we don't know
of any random distribution
that has these properties so it's a
better than random object which is kind
of crazy but nevertheless it's true
and really what i the way i view them
they're not pseudorandom they're
pseudo-dense
they're objects that are sparse but
locally they are very dense
now whether or not this can be useful to
construct this random objects why not i
mean expanders are so useful that i have
no idea how
any other questions
hi um is there also a sort of a zigzag
way of constructing high dimensional
expanders
oh looking some size pieces
sorry
or should i repeat the question
no i understood the question so the
question was is there a zigzag way to
construct high dimensional expanders
so there are many uh attempts and
several really beautiful combinatorial
constructions
of high dimensional graphs that have
certain expansion properties but
none of them
have the really good high dimensional
expander properties and when i say the
really good
as a benchmark i use this uh
notion of local to global uh
for me like a high dimensional expansion
expander
really a high dimensional expander if
when you look at the local pieces and
you know something about their expansion
you can deduce global expansion then it
has like the local to global
feature and the combinatorial
constructions that are like zigzag that
we have so far
they reach there almost but they don't
cross this barrier so that's a great
open question
thank you reed for the wonderful talk
to start of the day
thanks